ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋
[เพลง]
4-5 เดือนนี้เดือนนี้เดือน
ธันวาคมครับ 5 เดือนธันวาคมให้เดือน
ธันวาคม 5 ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะมีผช
2564 ครับหน้า
564 ๆเลยครับปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ
2010  21 ครับอ่าของพันธุ์ 21  21 นะคะๆ
ครับปีนี้
มันสุกแย่วันศุกร์
ตอนนี้กี่โมง Who อัดวันนี้ใช่ไหมครับตอน
นี้ที่รัก What  is ดูดูดูนาฬิกา
นาฬิกาอาฮ่านี่นาฬิกา
ตอนนี้เวลาคุณป้ากูอันตี้เข็มสั้นอ่ะเข็ม
นาฬิกามี 2 เข็มใช่ไหมคะได้ครับอยู่ที่
เลข 9 ทรายเข็มสั้นอยู่ที่เลข 9 ครับฮ่า
ฮ่าๆๆเจ้าอยู่เลข 3 เห็นยาวนี่เข็มยาว
อยู่ที่เลข 3 ใช่ครับก็เป็นเวลา
09:00 น 9:00 น 15 นาที 5 นาทีน
กลางคืน
ได้ครับเป็นกลางคืน
กลางคืนบางคืนอะมีพัดพระจันทร์ปีดาว
ใจเอามือ
อันนี้มึงก็ไม่เอามืดโอเคมืดแล้วมืดแล้ว
มองไม่เห็นเลยอ่ะโอเค 9:00 น 15 นาทีครับ
ตอนนี้แต่ตอนนี้นะคะ
ผู้สามทุ่มแล้วครับใกล้ๆเวลานอนใช่ครับ
ใกล้เวลานอนคู่เอ๋เอ๋อยากนอนหรือยังครับ
กูอ่ะหาวแล้วขอ
นอนฮ่าๆ
อย่างนอนเดี๋ยวครัวตี้กลัวที่จะชวนครูเอ๋
มาคุยคุยเรื่อง
ขนมฟ้องกินกินครับสวัสดีนี่ของจริงมีของ
กินก่อนเก็บตื่นค่ะตื่นก๋วยตื่นไม่นอน
แล้วนะไม่ให้นอน
มีอะไรให้ครูเอกกินเอ้ยคู๋ดูหรอๆครับมาดู
ก่อนก่อนมาดูของกินกันนี่ควรตีนของหน้า
อย่ากินหลายอย่างหลายอย่างใช้กับนี่ครับ
อย่างที่ 1
ที่หนึ่งอ้ะยัตนี่ครับว้าว
อีกขนมเหรอคะใช่ครับวิธีขนม
อ่ะประเทศนักเรียนก็จะมีขนมเค้กสายลม
คุกกี้
ขนมอะไรอ่ะ R
ครัวซองอ้าใช่มีใครพูดขนมนิขนมไทยอ่ะขนม
ของประเทศไทยกูอตี้ขนมมีสีมากๆง่ายทั้งขา
อ้านี่ขนมสี
สีส้มไหมสีส้มห้าสีชมพูสีชมพูเขียว
สีเขียวหมอเขาอ้อมีสีขาว
สีขาวขาวมีสีน้ำตาลข้างหลังนี้นี่สีน้ำ
ตาลชายครับถ้าหาคู่เห
ล้กรู้ขนมนี้เรียกขนมอะไรรู้ไหมครับคู๋
รู้จักเหรอ
ขนมนี้ชื่อชื่อชื่อชื่อ
อะไร
อ่ะชื่ออะไรครับอารัวใช่มั้ยคะขนมอาลัว
ใช้ครับนะครับอารมณ์กลัวมี
หลายสี
กัดเนี่ย
แข็งขายในนิ่มๆเอาข้างนอกแข็งข้างในนิ่ม
แล้วก็กินแล้วก็คือหญ้า
หวานของด้วยหอมรอบหอมๆๆๆ
ครูอาตี้ขาว Top กินขนมอาลัวไหมคะกลัวติด
ชอบกินขนมอาลัวครับชอบกินขนมปลาล้วนๆนะกู
อาทิตย์ชอบกินขนมอาลัวสีอะไรคะกลัวติ๊ก
กินทุกสี
ฮ่าๆๆสีเลยอ่ะกินทุกสี
จริงๆกินแล้วเหมือนกันแต่ว่าอะไรครับ
เหมือนกันครูเอ๋ชอบตอบสีอะไรครับซอย 4/4
น้ำตาลน่ะสีเขียวห้า
สีอะไรอีกครับพี่ครับขอ
ฮ่าๆๆ
สีเขียวสีชมพูไม่เอาสมเด็จ
สีส้มก็ไม่เอาใช่ไหม 4 ซ่อมไม่เอาเหมือน
กันนักเรียนกินแล้วเหมือนกันแต่ว่าได้รู้
หน้าไว้ว่าเหมือนกันชอบชอบสี
r14 ใช่มั้ยเอกชอบกินสีขาวมากๆกับสีน้ำ
ตาลสีเขียวนิดหน่อยโอเคอ่ะวันนี้ครัวตีมี
ขนมอาลัวแล้วมีขนมอีกมีขนมอย่างอื่นอีก
หรอคะใช่เขาอะไรคะอยากรู้อยากดูนี่ครับ
ว้าวมีสีมั้งเจ๊ใช่อ่ามีสีมากเลยขนมอะไร
คะครูอตี้ชื่ออะไรขนมอะเรียก
ลูกชุบลูกชุบด้วยครับลูกชุบเออกูจะดูแล้ว
ครูเอ๋มันเห็นเห็นพริก
หาใช่ครับมีปีกมีเบื่อเหมือนพริกแต่ไม่
ใช่พริกใช่รับแล้วมีส้มด้วยนะคะใช่ครับมี
ส้มมีต้มด้วยนี่ส้มส้ม
แอปเปิ้ลไหมสีเขียว
แอปเปิ้ลอันนี้หรอครับพี่ที่ใกล้ๆส่งมา
ค่ะออก
ได้ไหมอ๋ออาจจะเป็นแอปเปิ้ลหน้าเห้ยทุบ
เป็นขนมเอามาปั้น
ใช่ครับท่านเหมือน
อ่าเหมือนพริกเหมือนผลไม้เหมือนพริกอะไร
ครับก็ไปชุบเชอรี่อาซ้งอาหารภาษาไทยเรียก
วุ้นไปทุกวุ้นสี
ก็ต่างๆค่ะมีหลายสีหนึ่งค่ะมีสีสีอะไร
บ้างคะเนี่ยมีสีแดงสีม่วง
แจ้งสีม่วงอ่ะสีส้มสีชมพูหน่อยครับมีสี
เขียว
ๆครับปาร์ตี้ลูกชุบอยู่ใส่ในอะไรคะขอดู
YouTube ใส่ในกระทงกระทงใบต่อนี่เป็นไม่
ต้อง
ไม่ต้องไม่ต้องคือใบของกล้วยใช่ไหมคะๆ
ครับใบตองคือใบของกล้วยกล้วยจะมีใบใบ
กล้วยอ่ะคนไทยเรียกใบกล้วยว่าใบตองห่าใช่
ครับหะเดี๋ยวนะกลัวติ๊กต้องวาดรูปรวยด้วย
ไหมกล้วยเฮ้ยวาดนิดเฮ้ยเฮ้ยกล้วยกล้วย
โอเคอ่ากล้วยแม่นไหมคะกว่าที่ 5 พอได้
แล้วได้อยู่ได้อยู่นี้เป็นไปต่อ
ฮ่าๆนี่ใบตองสีเขียวเขียวๆๆ
อ้าว
ไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋มีคลิปไปตองอ๋อโอเค
ขนมลูกชุบอยู่ในกระทงใบตองจ้าแล้วจะส่งใบ
ตองนะโอ๊ยกูอ๊อฟฟี่หัวจี๊ดชอบกินขนมลูก
ชุบไหมคะควยตี้ชอบลูกชุบนิดหน่อยชอบกิน
นิดหน่อยไปครับไอ้ติ๊ดชอบอาลัวมากกว่าได้
ชอบอะรวมมากกว่ามากกว่าลูกชุบช่อง Allure
มากกว่าชายครับ
เวลาครูเอ๋เด็กๆ
ก็ชอบลูกชุบและก็อารัวๆ
ตอนนี้กูเอกโตอ่า
ไม่กินลูกชุบ
ขอไรครับน่ากินอะรวยดีกว่าอารัวอร่อยอ่า
โอเคขนมอย่างอื่นอีกไหมคะมีครับมีขนม
อย่างอื่นอีกนี่ครับนี่
ว้าวอันนี้ชอบกูอะตี้ไม่นอนแล้วกูเอก
ชอบ
กูเอกชอบอันนี้หรือชอบอันนี้ครับชอบสอง
อย่างเลยรอบสองอย่างเลยชอบอันนี้แล้วก็
ชอบอันนี้ด้วย
ใช่กูเอกชอบขนมของยอดน้อยอันนี้เครียดขนม
ทองหยอดนะเค้กชอบฝอยทองด้วยไปขออันนี้
เป็นขนมฝอยทอง
เออ
คู๋เมื่อก่อนกินคนเดียวขอกิโลกรัมวกินมาก
กิโลกรัมกินมากในเอายอด 1 กิโลกรัมดูทีวี
แล้วก็กินกินกิน
ครัวตี้ท่อบฝอยทอง
หน้าชอบทองหยอดนิดหน่อยห้ามหยอดหวานมากๆๆ
ต้องยี่ห้อหัว
มากๆ
อร่อยไม่อยากกินอยากกินตี้ตอนเนี้ยไม่
ง่วงแล้วถามทุ่มกว่าแล้วเห็นทองหยอดหิว
หิวว่ายังกินพรุ่งนี้กูอาจจะวิ่งไปซื้อ
ทองหยอดให้ซื้อเหรียญทองหยอด
[เพลง]
ทองหยอดฝอยทองอร่อยค่ะๆ
มีอีกปกติมีอะไรบ้างคะขนมไทยอีกมีขนมไทย
มามากหน้าวันที่มีขนมไทยมากๆนะๆๆๆอันนี้
อันนี้อันนี้ว้าว
kui เห็นเป็นฟักทองใช่ไหมคะค่ะนี่เป็น
ฟักทองใช่ครับฟักทองข้างบนเป็นฝอยทองใช่
มั้ยได้ข้างบนเป็นฝอยทองฝอยทองอยู่ข้างบน
นี้
ข้างในข้างในฝันของเป็นอะไรคะอ้าข้างใน
ฟักทองตรงนี้เป็นสังขยาครับอ๋ออ๋อสังขยา
หลายขนมอันนี้ชื่ออะไรคะขนมอันนี้ชื่อ
สังขยารับก็ฟักทองอามิสังขยามีสีทองงาน
got ใส่ฝอยทองเอ่ออยู่ข้างบนใส่ฝอยทอง
ไม่ใส่ก็ได้เนาะอ้าไม่ใส่ก็ได้ใส่สังขยา
กับฟักทองสองอย่างก็อร่อย
สายขับสังขยาฟักทองคือ app ที่ชอบกินไหม
คะ 5 ขวดที่ชอบกินสังขยาขาชอบทองนิดหน่อย
กู Arty ต้องกินด้วยกันของทีมสองอย่างกิน
ฟักทองกินสังขยาขออัดตีครูแอป tiktok
สังขยากินใช่ครับวัดทองนิดหน่อยรักสังขยา
เยอะ
โอเคเอาฟัด 2 ฟักทองให้เอ๋ชอบกินต้อง
พร้อม
กินสังขยานิดหน่อยเหรอ
หน้าสังขยาหวานมากฟักทองหวานนิดหน่อย
ใช่
หิวหิวอะพี่บีเอเอส BTS ใกล้ๆบ้านครูเอ๋
มีท้องยอร์ชก็พี่ฝอยทอง
สังขยาฟักทองมีสังขยาด้วยขอตัวไม่มีขอ
[เพลง]
มีลูกชุบด้วยว่ามีลูกชุบด้วยใช่กับครัวตี
ก็เห็นมีลูกชุบขายเยอะอ่าที่ได้โอ้ยหิว
กว่าตี้มีอย่างอื่นไว้อยากเห็นหน้าเห็น
แล้วคุยอยากกิน
มีครัวติ้งมีมีอีกครับมีต่อไปนี่เขารู้กู
นักเรียนนักเรียนเคยเคยกิน
ขนมอันนี้ไหมครับเคยใช่ไหม
ใช่นักเรียนเคยกินไหมอ่ะคิดรอบคิดว่านัก
เรียนน่าจะเคยกินน้า
ๆฮับมีอะไรคะนั่นอ่ะที่ขอให้อะไรอ่ะอัน
นี้หน้านี้เป็นข้าวเหนียวครับเข้าอยู่ที่
เก่าๆเป็นข้าวเหนียวบนข้าวเหนียวอะไรคะ
ข้างบนข้าวเหนียวเป็นสังขยาอ๋อสังขยามือ
เหมือนหา
สังขยาเหมือนสังขยาที่อยู่ในฟักทองนี่
เป็นสังขยาเหมือนกันใจครับแต่นี้อยู่บน
เข้าเหนียว
ครับ
แล้วข้างล่างข้าวเหนียวกับข้างล่างเท่า
เดี๋ยวอ๋อข้างล่างข้าวเหนียวก็เป็นเป็น
อะไรครับเมื่อกี้เมื่อกี้เป็นอะไรใบตอง
r&i ตองลองใช่นะคะเป็นใบตอง 555
แวะตีคะแล้วขนมอันนี้ชื่ออะไรคะอ้าขนมวัน
นี้ชื่อเข้าเหนียวสังขยา
ก็เขาเดี๋ยวสังขยา High เหมียวมีสังขยา
เรียกข้าวเหนียวใส่ R5 อร่อยอร่อยมาก
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่ชอบข้าวเหนียวสังขยา
มากที่สุดแต่งตีมากสุดเลยตรงนี้เลยปัญหา
ทิ้งเออติเดี๋ยวมวยไทยการพ่อเอกก็ชอบจะ
แย่งพ่อมากผมจะยาวมากเหมือนกันใช่มั้ยอ่ะ
ครูเอกปล่อยอร่อย
กดพี่คุยหิว
หิวเยอะแล้ว
ชอบสังขยาฟักทองครูเอกก็ชอบเหมือนกันนะ
น้ำมีขนมอย่างอื่นอีกไหมคะคุณครูก็เริ่ม
อยากจะกินแล้วใช่ไหมครับตอนนี้มีขนมเห็น
เดินเดินไปแล้วก็ช็อปปิ้งขนม
r-vit ขนมไทยโอเคนี่ครับขนมไทยต่อไปอ่า
เห็นเห็นอะไรครับ
เดี๋ยวใช่ครับมีเขาเหนียวนี่เป็นข้าว
เหนียวแล้วไม่เห็นด้วย 5 นี่ข้างในในข้าว
เหนียวมีกล้วยได้ค่ะ
ขนมนี่เรียกว่าอะไรคะขนมนี้เรียกข้าวต้ม
กับ
ข้าวต้มมัดข้าวต้มมัดใจครับไม่นี่ครับ
เพราะว่าข้าวต้มเนี่ยมาร์ชมิมัดติดการ
ข้าวต้มสองอันนี้ข้าวต้มสองอันมัดติดกัน
แล้วก็มัดมีครับใช้ใช้อะไรมัดทะกว่าท้าย
อือก็บอกต่อใช่ครับตอกทำมาจากไม้ไผ่
ฮ่องไผ่
เดี๋ยวตีว่าต้นไผ่ต้นใหม่ก็จะเป็นต้นไป
สูงแบบนี้ต้นไผ่นะกลัวที่ว่าต้นใหม่ต้อง
ขึ้นวันนี้แล้วก็มีแน่ต้นไผ่ค่ะได้ครับมี
ใบมีใบอะใบไผ่
อ้าแล้วก็เอามาทำต่อค่ะใช่ค่ะมัดนะคะๆเอา
มามัดข้าวต้ม
มัดต่อมคนไทยก็เรียกเข้าต้มมัด
อ้าวต้มมัดนะคะ
อร่อยไหมคะอ่ะข้าวต้มมัดอร่อยครับอร่อย
ครู Arty ชอบกินไหมคะอ่าชอบกินอ่าชอบกิน
ชอบกินสังขยาเท่านี้ชอบกินข้าวต้มมาพญา
ถ้าไม่เอาท่าไหนมาสลัดต้มมัดอ่า
Allure อยู่ข้างล่างทุกแถวๆๆฮ่าๆๆมัน
ขยายผ่อนทองรายวัน
นี้กูเอกก็ชอบชอบฮ่า
หิว
เอไม่ได้กินขนมนาน
9 เดือน
ว้าว 9 เดือนอยู่ในบ้านไม่ได้ออกจากบ้าน
ก็ไม่ได้กินขนมแล้วซื้อขนมกินหอมเฮ้ออยาก
กินใช่อย่า in ล้อเวฟดูแล้วพรุ่งนี้ไป
ซื้อขนมค่ะฮ่าๆๆ
มีอีกไหม
ตีนมีขนมเยอะเลยวันนี้มีให้ครูขิวๆ B
ขนมจีบครับนี่เฮาส์อ่าอันนี้ครูเอ๋ชอบ
สวัสดีคิดคิดว่าครูเอกชอบทุกๆอยากห่างเลย
ชอบหมดเลยชอบอันนี้ว่าขอชอบอันนี้มากที่
สุดนู่นเลยใช่ไหมอ้าวชอบก็ชอบ
หาขนมไทยอร่อย
อ่ะแล้ว
เรียกว่าเรียกว่าขนมอะไรครับอันนี้ถ้า
น้องๆอันนี้มี
บางทีพูด 2 ชื่อไหมขนมใส่ไส้หาครับกับ
อะไรครับนิสัยไส้แล้วมีอะไรอีกครับสอดไส้
ป่ะอ๋อก็ขาดใกล้คนสอบคอร์ดๆบางคนใส่ไส้
แต่เหมือนกันเหมือนกันครูพูดขนมใส่ไส้อ๋อ
เออครัวตี้ก็พูดว่าขนมมีไส้อ้าอร่อยอ่ะ
อันนี้ตอนนี้นี่ครับตรงนี้เป็นไส้ไส้ไส้
หวานไส้หวานๆใช่ไหม
ใช่แล้วก็สีขาวจะเข็มเข็มๆๆอ้าหวานหวาน
เค็มๆ
กูเอชอบที่เข้าห่อสวยค่ะผัวเตะตายครับเขา
ห่อใบต้องหนีใช้ใบตองไม่ต้องห้องนี่เป็น
ทรงและสุกไปมะพร้าวถ้ามีใบมะพร้าวด้วยน่า
อร่อยค่ะนักเรียนนักเรียนมาประเทศไทยนะคะ
ดูเอกคิดนักเรียนอ่ะจะชอบกินอยู่ขนมใส่
ไส้แหละนักเรียนกินได้
เค้าต้มมัดข้าวต้มมัด
นักเรียนจะกินได้เพราะว่าไม่หวานอ่ะหญ้า
หวานนิดหน่อยอ่าอะไรคะ
พอนักเรียนบางทีไม่ชอบม้าหวานนักเรียนไม่
กินชายๆไส้น่ะโอเคเลยอ่าเขาต้มก็โอเคโอเค
ๆนี่ก็กลมเข้าหวานๆหน่อยๆไปค่ะๆๆ
อีกเค้าต้มขนมใส่ไส้ว่าตีคู๋จะพูดไม่ได้
แล้วเนี่ยเพราะครูเอ๋จะหิว
ยังมีไม่อย่างหนึ่งอีกนะอย่างสุดท้ายใช่
ครับอ่ามีอีกอย่างไรคะหน้าคู่เอกคิดถึง
ขนมอะไรครับตอนนี้คิดว่าตอนนี้หน้าหนาว
หนาวต้องกินขนมร้อนๆอ๋อขนมร้อนๆมีน้ำซุป
ด้วยใช่ไหม
ใช่เลยก็
เลยครับอ่ะ
มีกี่สีคะเนี่ยโหนี้มีหลายสีเลยนี่มีลม
กลมๆกล่องกลมสีสีอะไรครับสีน้ำเงินสี
น้ำเงินครับ
สีฟ้าสีฟ้าใช่ไหมโอเคโอเคเออ
ที่ 1 อ่านนิคมกลมสีอะไรครับตรงนี้สิสี
เหลืองและสีส้มสีเหลืองสีเหลือง
ลายสีเหลือง
แล้วก็อันนี้เป็นสีสีเขียวห้าสีเขียวอ้าว
พกตรงนี้มีตรงนี้เป็นสีอะไรครับสีขาวค่ะ
หาวๆเย้วิธีที่ 5 ด้วยนี่ครับนี่
สีม่วงๆๆๆๆสีม่วงนะครับอ่ะปีที่แล้วก็มี
อะไรคะสีขาวกับสีส้มอ๋อตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
ตรงนี้เป็นไข่ใช่ครับไข่อ่าอีกไทยถึงกัน
หนาวกับไข่สีแดงอ่ากูไอ้อยากรู้แล้วใช่
ไหมครับว่าขนมชื่ออะไรใช่ไหมจะละลายนัก
เรียนอยากรู้เหทิศให้ครู Arty พูดล้มชื่อ
อะไร
น้ำลายคู่ขนมนี้ชื่อขนมบัวลอยนี่ตรงนี้
บัวลอยตรงนี้ข่ายไข่หวานๆไปหวานบัวลอยไข่
หวานงามีน้ำมีน้ำนี่มีน้ำถ้ามีน้ำเป็นน้ำ
กระทิครับอ่าน้ำกะทินะคะนิหน่าน้ำกะทิ
หลังจากทำมาจากอะไรกูอีกรู้ไหมลบพร้าว R
ใช่ครับน้ำกะทิทำมาจากมะพร้าวอ่านี่ครับ
มีมะพร้าวอยู่ตรงนี้อีกมะพร้าวสีทองชาย
ตรงนี้ช้าใช่ความ
ทำมาจากมะพร้าวแล้วก็น้ำตาลมะพร้าว
ลายครับนาคากะที่มีมะพร้าวนักเรียนตัวเอง
มีต้นมะพร้าวไหนครับต้นมะพร้าว
และก็มีลูกลูกมะพร้าว
นะเอามะพร้าวมารักมีน้ำหา
น้ำจากลูกมะพร้าวใช่ไหมครับ
ก็
มะพร้าวมะพร้าวนั้นเองไปดูคลิปทะเล
คลิปทะเลมีมะพร้าวหมอเขาอยู่มีต้นมะพร้าว
อยู่ข้างๆด้วยสร้างมาขาดอะตีตอนนี้หนาว
หนาวนะกินบัวลอยไข่หวานโอ
อร่อยมากๆดู Altis  shop ไหมคะกลัวแต่ชอบ
ครับชอบบัวลอยนะครับแต่ว่าเวลากลัวตีกิน
ควรติไม่ชอบไข่อ่ะคนที่ชอบกินบัวลอยไม่
ชอบกินไข่จ้าใช่ก็ไม่ต้องใส่ไข่บอกไม่นาย
เอาบัวหลอดเดิน
วันที่เดินไปซื้อเบาะบัวลอย 1 ถุง
ไข่ไม่เอาไข่
เอาบัวลอย
กู Altis ชอบกินบัวลอยสีอะไร
ที่กินทุกสีตัวที่ไม่มีใจกับใหม่จะเลือก
วิธีนี้อร่อยอ๋อชอบสีเหลืองก็เจ้าสีอะไร
ครับโอเคชอบสีเหลืองกับสีเขียวกับสีอยาก
คุยก็กินสีเหลืองก่อนกินสีเขียวก่อนสีฟ้า
ยังไม่กินไอ้สีน้ำเงินยังไม่กินอ่ะ
สีเหลืองก่อนนะอ่าโอเคสีเหลืองอร่อยที่
สุดผู้เอง
คิดนะคะ
กูอะที่บอกเหมือนกันอะไรเหมือนกันให้
เลือกกินอย่างเดียวมายเรือสีเหลืองเป็น
ฟักทองกับครู Arty อ๋อใจกับสิ่งหลวงสี
เหลืองทำมาจากฟักทองอ่าแกแล้วสีเขียวทำมา
จากอะไรครับเป็นใบไม้ขอเป็นใบไม้
กวนตีคิดว่าใบไม้สีเขียวน้ำหอมด้วยนิ
กลิ่น
หอมให้อ่ะ
ใบเตยๆแล้วเรียกใบเตย kuai จะวิ่งไปเก็บ
ให้กู Arty ดูได้ไหมอ่ะบ้านกูเองมีใบเตย
ด้วยหรอมีค่ะกูอะดิปรอยๆครับฝนตี๋หล่อได้
หล่อรพ.ได้ครับคุณที่มีเวลาอ้าโอเคตอนนี้
ครูเอ๋วิ่งไปวิ่งไปเก็บใบเตยบ้านกูเอ๋มี
ใบเตยด้วยครับนักเรียนว้าวบ้านครัวตี้ไม่
มีให้กลัวที่ไม่มีมั้ยเตยแต่บ้านกูเอ๋มี
ใบเตยครับ
เฮ้ยแล้วเวฟมาเร็วมากเลยอ่ะอ๋อใบเตยสี
เขียวสีเขียวแล้วก็เหมียวอ๋อๆหน้ามีกลิ่น
หอมสีสีเขียวอ๋อเอาใบเตยมาทำบัวลอยสี
เขียวน้อยๆงานห้ามไปทยสีห้อหอม
โหตีวันนี้หรอกก็มีขนมเยอะเลยนะคะนายมี
ขนม
พูดอีก 1 ครั้งเนาะอันนี้ได้ครับบัวลอย
ไข่หวานบัวลอยไข่หวานใช่ครับ 5 เอาป้าย
ค่ะหน้าอันนี้ขวดตีจำได้ว่า Talk อัน
นี้ชอบ
ที่สุดใจนะ
อันนี้ขนมใส่ไส้ครับขนมใส่ทรายใต้นะครับ
หน้าผับๆนี้นับขนมอะไรคะนักเรียนยังจำได้
ไหมอ่ะอ่านิขนมข้าวต้มมัดครับฮ่าาเขาก็มา
นายครับอ่าต่อไปครับต่อไปเป็นมีขนมอะไรคะ
เอออันนี้อันนี้กว่าที่คิดว่านักเรียนจำ
วันนี้ได้จำเข้าเดี่ยวได้อ่าใช่ไหมเข้า
เหนียวสังขยาครับขนมข้าวเหนียวสังขยาๆผัว
ตีชอบขนมข้าวเหนียวสังขยามากที่สุดฮ่าๆๆ
ไปเอาจำได้ต่อไปครับกลับไปขนมอะไรคะอัน
นี้ฟักทองสังขยา
ว้าวค่ะอย่าแค่ต่อไปครับขนมอะไรคะอ้าวัน
นี้ E  2 อย่างใช่ครับมีขนมทองหยอดหน้า
ทองหยอดแล้วก็ฝอยทองค่ะทองหยอดขนมฝอยทอง
ขนมทองหยอดกลมกลมๆกลมๆของย่อหน้าเราก็ต่อ
ไปทองเป็นเส้นไปเล่นเส้นค่ะไม่ได้ครับ
โอเคต่อไป
ขนมอะไรดี
ขนมลูกชุบครับขนมลูกชุบ
[เพลง]
หอมใบเตยออกใบเตยใช่ไหม
ลูกชุบสีเขียวก็มีใบเตยมี่ถ้าให้ครับ
อ่าต่อมามานี้ครับขนมอันแรกเลยขนมอะไรคะ
ขนมอันนี้ขนมอาลัว
อาลัวอยู่นะคะครับไม่รั่ว
ขออ้าววันนี้วันนี้ครู Arty มีขนมมาให้
นักเรียนดูๆได้ค่ะ
ครูเอกก็ขิวฮ่าๆๆๆ
แปลว่าตอนนี้เนี่ย
ก็สามทุ่มกว่าๆจะ 22:00 นใช่
ขอเฮ้ยตอนนี้ไม่มี
ไม่มีขนมขายแล้วผัวที่ให้เอาตอนนี้ซื้อ
ขนมไม่ได้แล้วไม่ได้แล้วนะคะฟังคืนแล้วก็
ได้นะคะ
นักเรียนนักเลงคอมเม้นข้างล่างนะคะนัก
เรียนรู้จักขนมที่ครู Arty เอามาให้นัก
เรียนดูไหมคะรู้จักไหมครับ 555 รู้จัก
ครับถ้าจากถ้ารู้จักนะพิมพ์ชื่อขนมที่รู้
จักหน้าที่รู้จักลงมาแล้วและเรียนเคยกิน
ขนม
วันที่เอามาไหมคะ
กินอะไรอ่ะขอ
รหัสกินขนมอะไรนะขนมเคยกินขนมอะไร
ราคานักเรียนคอมเม้นข้างล่างนะคะขับราคา
ว่านักเรียนชอบขนมไทยไหมแอบกินอะไร
นะคะขอ
ยังมีเวลาไม่ขวาตี้กลัวที่คิดว่าคิดว่า
เราต้องไปแล้วไปแล้วนอนใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่นอน
ถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าคราวหน้าเรากลับมา
เจอครัวตี้เจอคู่เอ๋กันใหม่นะครับถ้าเรา
เจอกันตอนกลางคืนเราก็ต้องพูดว่า
ราตรีสวัสดิ์ค่ะราตรีสวัสดิ์ครับครูเอ๋า
ราตรีสวัสดิ์สวัสดิ์เกรียนผมไปบายๆ
ม.ค